congratulations on being named a plan
international canada global ambassador i
mean
how excited were you when they wanted
you to be a part of this
i was so excited like honestly like it
was just such an
honor to first of all have them be
willing to work with me
i didn't even care about like global
ambassadors yet i was like wow this is
just
awesome that i get to be a part of such
a great organization too
well with plan international canada i
mean they're dedicated to advancing
children's rights and equality for young
girls why is this an organization
that is so close to your heart well for
me
education like the right to education
especially for children
really really does matter a lot to me
because i'm privileged to say that you
know i've had such a great education
that led me to be where i am today right
so i'd want
everybody to have a similar experience
to have that right to learn
because knowledge is power and of course
plan international canada
they do such a great job of going into
communities and
making real change that is lasting
rather than just performative and
surface level
yeah definitely um plan international re
released their free to be online report
i mean it's pretty staggering the
numbers of women who have to face online
harassment every day
you know girls and women what they have
to deal with were you surprised with the
the high number that came out i hate to
say
that i wasn't but i wasn't you know
because like
nowadays we really normalize harassment
online which is totally not okay
we normalize this idea of if you put
yourself out there on the internet
you have to expect that you're gonna be
harassed but
harassment is harassment and it's not
okay to experience such a thing
yeah i mean i i feel like every
so many people right now especially
women if you have a big presence online
um there's going to be some form of
harassment so have you yourself dealt
with online bullying
yeah for sure when especially when like
the show dropped of course
you know there's a difference between
getting critique right about the show or
whatever
you know content you're putting out
there and there's like this critique of
like
oh i just didn't like the plot of this
part and it's like okay
cool we'll work on it but then when it
becomes more personal to
an actual attack on you or maybe your
family your friends
that's just wrong that's just bluntly
wrong and
i have a lot of friends who also
experience such a thing
because like the stats show it's a huge
problem
yeah do you have any advice or or just
you know from your own experience how
people can get
through dealing with online bullying i
would say
honestly like i'm not gonna say some
advice of like oh
take a break get offline i'm not gonna
say that because
you shouldn't have to you shouldn't have
to be told oh just don't put out this
kind of content
i'm not going to tell a woman when she's
walking down the street don't wear that
kind of top
we've got to address the people who are
doing such an act who are
creating this environment and then of
course the social media companies that
are helping perpetuate this
environment that normalizes harassment
i would say hey look to your friends and
the people you trust who actually know
you
for support but don't hold back on your
voice
on the internet yeah i love that well um
like everybody i feel um i was such a
huge fan of never have i ever
you're so good in it you're so funny
do you have any updates on season two
when production will start or has
everything just kind of been put on hold
yeah well we're gonna be starting
production soon but i know
i speak on behalf of the cast and the
crew we just want to make sure
everything's super safe
because like never have i ever is great
and all but
in the grand scheme of things it just
bluntly does not matter
compared to the lives actual lives so we
want to make sure everything's safe
before we start up again
yeah um what are you looking forward to
most when it comes to your character in
season two and what fans are gonna get
to see
man i'm i'm so excited to just know what
happens next like i just wanna know
like where does everybody go from here i
wanna know like is davey still a hot
mess
is she gonna somehow get it together i
don't know but i'm excited to see
all the characters just have their arcs
you know
each character is just written so well
yeah
you know this is a show that i'm
honestly i watched with my whole family
we watched in a day we just had like a
binge day we're like this is the best
show ever
were you surprised by all the love that
you got on this show
i'm still surprised i don't yeah i don't
get i
when they said like over 40 million you
know devices
within the first month we're streaming
never have i ever i'm like
yo what like you guys willingly put my
face on your screen
and you somehow like it's not even like
you just put your face
my face on your screen and stop no you
like watch the whole thing
yeah what okay okay that's cool
like did you know this is gonna be a
show that would connect with people or
regis happy
that you're on this show and that you
loved your character oh 100
was just happy to be a part of such a
creative you know project
but i knew like with the writing like
being on set like i knew like this is
gonna be a hit like this is gonna be
a show that people are gonna wanna watch
all over the world
but i didn't i couldn't fathom how
big the world is i guess yeah yeah no
it's true
yeah um now have you stayed in contact
with mindy have you been able
to tell her about you know being a plan
international canada global ambassador
yeah actually all of like the whole cast
mindy lang
everybody really they're all super
stoked for me and you know we're all
like one big family so whenever we have
you know achievements we you know do
something good we always let each other
know
so yeah very cool well another toronto
girl iman valani has been cast as miss
marvel
so i don't know what your reaction was
to that news
i'm so stoked that marvel took the time
to properly find somebody who accurately
represents kamala khan but then also
like she's canadian so that's
awesome i mean like my stance still
stays the same
every good cast has a canadian
so thank you lonnie uh good for you
but i'm so stoked for her like i'm so
glad it's an accurate representation of
the character
and i realized like she's only 17 which
is where i was
a year ago and i'm like wow you're gonna
kill it like i'm i'm so excited for her
okay so you were thrown into hollywood
all of a sudden you were everywhere so
do you have any advice for her
as a 17 year old advice
what do i know i don't know i don't know
anything um
i would say i would if i could say like
a anything
which i'm probably she'll she'll hear in
a bunch of different directions
is to just you know keep her close
friends and her close family close to
her and
you know know that she's got support but
hey
i guarantee you probably within a month
she'll be
able to teach me a bunch of things so
i'm excited for her i love that okay
well i have one more question for you
i want to know what you've been doing
during you know
the past couple of months obviously it's
been a challenging time for a lot of
people some people
have found new hobbies so i just want to
know kind of what's been keeping you
going making you happy
yeah um a lot of video games video games
yeah
great um also violin i've been trying to
learn violin
i got one before quarantine for my
birthday because i've been wanting to
learn for a long time
but then quarantine hit so i can't do
lessons so i was like hey i'll just
teach myself
it is hard violin is hard
it's really hard but i then also like
whenever i get frustrated with violin i
just go back to piano because that's
like my main instrument so
yeah we're keeping busy i just love this
you're a star you can play piano you
want to learn violin who are you
bro i don't know i don't even know i
can't tell you